you mentioned
science fiction on the phone so let's go
with the ridiculous first what's the
greatest sci-fi
novel of all time in your view and maybe
what ideas do you find philosophically
fascinating about it
the greatest sci-fi novel of all time is
dune
and the second greatest is the children
of dune and
the third greatest is the god emperor of
you and so i'm a huge fan of the whole
uh series i mean it's just an incredible
world
that he created and i don't know if
you've read the book or not
no i have not it's one of my biggest
regrets
especially because the new movie is
coming out right everyone's super
excited about it i used to
it's ridiculous to say i'm sorry to
interrupt
is that i used to play the video game
used to be
dune that's i guess you would call that
real time strategy right right i think i
remember that game
yeah it's kind of awesome 90s or
something i think i played it actually
when i was in russia
i definitely remember it i was not in
russia anymore i think
at the time that i used to live in
russia i think video games were about
like
the suspicion of pong i think pong was
pretty much like the greatest game i
ever got to play
in russia which was still a privilege
right in that age so you didn't get
color
you didn't get like uh so i left russia
in 1991 right 191 okay so
i always wanted to feel like a kiss
because my mom was a programmer so i
would go to
her work right i would take the the
metro i've got to work and play like on
i guess the equivalent of like a 286 pc
you know
nice with floppy disks yes so okay but
back to you
get back to dune and by the way the new
movie
i'm pretty interested in but they're
skeptical
i'm a little skeptical i'm a little
skeptical i saw the trailer uh
i don't know so there's there's a david
lynch movie dune as you may know i'm a
huge david lynch fan by the way
so the movie is somewhat controversial
but
it's a little confusing but it captures
kind of the mood of the
book better than i would say like most
any adaptation
and like do you know so much about kind
of mood in the world right
but back to the philosophical point so
in the fourth book
god emperor of dune there's a sort of
setting where
lito one of the characters he's become
this weird sort of
god emperor he's turned into a gigantic
worm and you kind of have to read the
book to understand what that means so
the worms are involved
worms are involved you probably saw the
worms in the trailer right yeah and in
the video
so it kind of like merges with the swarm
and becomes this tyrant of the world and
like oppresses the people for a long
time right but he has a purpose
and the purpose is to kind of uh break
through
kind of a stagnation period in
civilization right
but people have gotten too comfortable
right and so he kind of
oppresses them so that they explode and
like
go on to colonize new worlds and kind of
renew the forward momentum of humanity
right
and so to me that's kind of like
fascinating right you need a little bit
of
pressure and suffering right to kind of
like make progress
not not not get too comfortable
okay maybe that's a bit of a rule
philosophy to take away but
that seems to be the case unfortunately
obviously i'm a huge fan of suffering
you